also this afternoon here at 4 keeping
the community safe during this pandemic
that is the goal of metro police and the
reason behind their new holiday safety
initiative
metro says they're trying to prevent and
reduce crime with this new
strategy uniformed officers and plane
close
officers will be in areas that are high
value targets for criminals
areas where most shoppers tend to go
just because you see
an increase in police officer presence
know that that doesn't necessarily mean
that there's a crime happening that we
are there to keep you
and the patrons and the community safe
also understand and especially for
criminals if you are watching this
just because you do not see a police
officer in a uniform
does not mean that we don't have a
police officer presence
metro says that since they launched this
initiative on saturday
they have made a significant arrest in
the northwest part of the valley
criminals that were targeting stores and
of course people shopping with their
packages